[Musique]
l'appétit des chinois pour les arachides
se fait sentir au sénégal cette année
les cultivateur de cacahuètes sénégal
elle ne travaille pas pour des pinottes
la chine qui se nourrit leur production
leurs offres et des prix plus alléchant
que sur le marché local en raison de la
forte demande chinoise
les exportations d'arachide au sénégal
ou doublé en cinq ans pour atteindre 200
mille tonnes
mais ce qui fait le bonheur des uns fait
le malheur des autres
ils transformateurs d'huile peine à se
procurer leurs matières premières
1500 emplois sont menacés un ménage sur
quatre cultive l'arachide au sénégal
c'est la principale culture du pays
[Musique]